yeah I'm John Gill the last sort of 20
years I've been working about 20 years
ago I went to work in Bermuda at a
reinsurance company and let me let me
just have a show of hands so we got any
people from the finance industry here oh
okay insurance oh dear okay
so the insurance people kind of know
what that industries like reinsurance is
is is like we're in England so you go
down the bookkeepers and you put a bet
on on a horse and and a small bookkeeper
they'll get worried if there's a lot of
bets on the one horse they won't be able
to pay everybody they lay off the bet
insurers do the same thing if they've
got you if you're a Florida insurer
you've been insured a lot of homes there
you get worried if there's going to be a
hurricane we're not going to be able to
pay so I had a previous career with the
British government won't talk about took
that but in 97 I was actually trying to
get to Canada I saw this job it said
supercomputing in Bermuda I said I mean
so anyway this talk I was asked to give
it I was down in in the Caribbean at a
Python conference he said can you give a
talk in pay date I said great I'll do it
so came up with the title it was
originally cap modeling with snakes and
I wanted my wife to help me with it and
she doesn't do snakes so we have to
change it to Python because she has this
morbid fear of snakes so the next
question I got when I sent the the talk
title off they said cat cat modeling it
so cats catastrophes and I said yes but
so this is my cat snowy which is also a
bit of a catastrophe in the world in the
in the laundry that there was the
morning after hurricane Faye which hit
Bermuda in 2014 we actually had two
hurricanes hit the island inside a week
and it was it was a crazy time on the
island I didn't have electricity for a
month I spent all my time working down
the pub because they did have
electricity it was quite convenient
actually so what I'm going to talk about
today if you've come here to see code
and learn exactly how to model cats in
with Python you're probably gonna be a
bit disappointed I told you so if you
want to talk about that more detail
after I'd love to I'm going to give you
a brief history of sort of how the
industry got where it is today and my
own sort of career there I turned up in
Bermuda at this insurer and and they
were doing assault it was going to be
these really sophisticated simulations
of detailed horican models and and and
really it was just multiplying numbers
together and and they were really mostly
just trying to work out they'd get
insurers coming to them and they'd say
that we've got all these policies this
is the business we've written and they
were trying to work out really what the
last distribution was likely to be from
this company and figure out how much to
charge them for the cover they wanted so
there's going to be some Perl and Python
they're the nearest thing I could find
to the pearly gates at a park in Bermuda
this thing on the bottom is is a if you
come to Bermuda and and they're trying
to persuade me to organize a PI data in
Bermuda and you're all welcome it'd be
fantastic there's pink sands and
sunshine and it might be in February so
it might not be the best weather but
it'll be better than the weather here
what you're supposed to do with these
these moon gates they're all over
Bermuda you make a wish as you go
through it well I for a while I used a
language called TCL's anyone heard a
tcl/tk you too it was great to run your
program you tried wish and that's what I
do every time I run my code you kind of
wish that it's going to run so the
bitter history math not too much history
there will be more cat snow he has given
me his release notes for the day he says
I can use these pictures
this is him writing code he's not very
good and this is that she just where I
live and that's sweeping up after the
second oricon that hitters in a week the
slide above was actually kind of cool we
had a PI day at one of the schools in
Bermuda and chattin oe Dekker he does a
robotics course and he decorated it up
with old PI symbols and we got the kids
in there's quite a lot of community
things going on in Bermuda
it's just it's a tiny island and
everybody it's the weirdest thing
there's lots of people doing separate
initiatives and most of us don't know
about each other even though it's only
25 square miles so the talks gonna be
old school now old school here this this
chap he's a deejay in Bermuda fantastic
guy he's an old-school DJ he plays old
music and he is so old-school that he
does these music off round things the
CDs now I remember when CDs with the
coolest thing on the planet if you had a
CD player and you were playing your
music with these things you could dance
without the needle scratching your
records fantastic things and these two
guys are fantastic too and they they
Doge as and they're just wonderful so I
turned up in Bermuda in 1997 and they
said well I said where's the
supercomputer said well it's this SDI
Challenger so it had 256 megabytes of
memory you measured its speed in mega
flops and we had a grand total of 3
gigabytes of disk that was for
everything actually they had a second
machine that we used his backups but
that was a little bit different and they
didn't like me using that one nowadays
you can buy Raspberry Pi this one here
$35 on this SDI challenger cost about
$100,000 back in the day Raspberry Pi
you get a gigabyte of memory its
measured in gigaflops and and the 10 you
know the $20 SD card is has 32 gigabytes
of storage and it's much faster than the
3 gigabyte a disc way out and I guess
the other point is actually in a real
supercomputer back in that day in the
80s if you bought a Cray XMP cost you
tens of millions of dollars you need a
room this size diverting a massive power
supply that raspberry pie is as powerful
as a Cray XMP was so the message here is
today compute power has become
essentially free I mean this thing runs
on a phone charger it's magic so I
turned up I was the pesky consultant at
this fancy reinsurance company so they
wouldn't let me use the SDI challenges
they had fantastic terminals it was
space-age it was one
but I was I I wasn't allowed that so
managed to get a laptop and managed to
install the SD eyes were running UNIX so
I needed something that I could do
unix-like coding on and there was this
newfangled thing called Red Hat Linux
and I had a friend who managed to get it
onto a laptop to me it was fantastic
this had an incredible 64 megabytes of
memory in it I think it was an Intel
Pentium and it had a 1 gigabyte disk and
I I started writing C++ code and there
was somebody who used to work with me
well I keep I keep bumming ink to people
from this former company and have to
apologize for my C++ code because
they're still using it it's a little bit
sad fast forward a couple of years the
SGI machine had a disk failure so we got
the backup tape out and the backup tape
did what backup tapes do it didn't read
and you know they came to me and they
said well can we can we
by the way the pictures may not make any
reference see so long story short the SD
eyes were costing us about $30,000 a
year just for the support contracts
dello just announced you could get a
high end server with read out 5.1 on it
and it had a 36 gigabyte disk 512 Meg of
RAM and this xeon cpu and i was like
well let's get one of those on and my
boss wanted me to port the code to
Windows and I didn't want to do that
because I don't do windows so I said
well let's get one of these Intel boxes
and we'll first see if our code runs on
Intel I said ok well so the first box
that they built at this company in 1999
they bought one of these I called it
Galois cuz I named all my computers
after mathematicians and long story
short we ported the code there was a bit
of a problem with sti's and an Intel box
has had a different
difference of opinion and about which
way or round you should store bytes in
floating-point numbers and had to fix a
bunch of file but started to work turn
there at the code round twice as fast on
this this SDI box that only cost five
thousand dollars now instead of oh sorry
on this Intel box it instead of hundred
thousand dollars and we're only four or
five years later it's running twice as
fast
my boss forgot about the Windows thing
we bought some more of these and we did
all our production on that life was good
fast forward I think was only about six
months later one of the bosses came to
me and he said you wanted me to build a
system and I had to call it compass well
there was a reason I could call it
compass was it any objectives for the
year he'd said that he was going to
create a system called compass so we you
came to me says I don't care what he
does but he going to call it compass
it's all fine and what we was it was a
system for aggregating portfolios of
contracts and it was a great place to
work because they lay they gave me a lot
of freedom there that I don't know why
they must have been mad but I come up
with good stuff from now so I used to so
I went with tea I decided in my wisdom I
was going to write this thing in TCL to
control language it is it was created at
Sun and it was a bit like Perl bit like
Python and and the thing that was great
about it it would run on Linux and
Windows and then pretty much any machine
you could you could get this this on the
Left actually is Dido and it came with a
GUI toolkit called TK that I think had
started life weed but in the Perl and
that on the left is a clock that ghido
actually wrote sceeto the Python man
rotors in TK used to have a clock like
this on his kitchen war with rotating
disks
the trouble with TK and TK tickle it
took so long to start up that you had to
put a flash green up when you started
your application so I used to display
the compass from the top of the City
Hall in Bermuda nobody who used this
application and they all lived in
Bermuda never realized what it
and I had a competition one time there
was free beer if he got it right nobody
could do it anyway goes on a couple of
years I realized the tickle was actually
not the best computer language in the
world it was very quick to lash things
together and and and and bolt together
your shell scripts but didn't really
have any data structures to speak of it
had these sort of dictionary like things
but they were painful to use kept
hearing about this thing called Python
and because I was I be using Linux tools
all the time and people would say oh you
should script it with Tyson so I won one
Christmas I got a book and I read about
Python oh and they sold me at the white
space thing I don't have to type curly
braces I mean so anyway where we needed
to replace compass it was creaking under
its its weight and so a friend of mine
II who worked on the project I don't
know whether he's Richard here he is I
think it was your idea to call it GPS
it's better compass so that's what we
called it and it was actually one of the
few times I've worked on a software
project where they decide to do the
second generation of something and it
actually worked
I don't know whether any of you been
involved in any projects like that if
anyone ever says we need to replace this
with a new generation thing run it's not
gonna work
so you're working in reinsurance it's
what I call event-driven development
what happens is everything's going great
you think you're going to be working on
something for the next month and then a
hurricane comes along and plans change
suddenly the most important thing is
improving our hurricane models because
we just were found out they weren't very
good so back to back to even little
digression here it was always a
challenge I was working on Linux I was
producing numbers for them and they
liked that but every so often somebody
these people like to see charts and
plots and graphs and back in about 2000
and
pythons plotting situation wasn't
terribly good there was a package called
Chacko that we use for one thing and
we'd have to produce all these plots
once a quarter for the board book and
for reporting to the SEC and all that
and what would happen in between one
quarter and an X we don't grade the
Machine and Jaco would stop working so
I'm Google in one day someone says never
mind shackle use matplotlib it's
brilliant well I'll give it to world by
the way they this is this is when you
come to Bermuda that's the pink Sun that
you get to enjoy so I'll have a look at
matplotlib well I have to produce a plot
that looks like this a stacked bar chart
goes basically if you've used Excel this
is what Excel produces and unfortunately
my chance had to look exactly like Excel
otherwise they weren't going to be happy
so again matplotlib it doesn't do stack
bar charts but I'm I was working in
Dublin at the time then I get the train
home at the night I've downloaded the
code and it was brilliant
I could actually follow this code and I
found the bar chart code few lines of
code change we had stacked bar charts
next morning on the way into the Train a
tidied up a bit had got the patch ready
and I emailed it after John Hunter was
managing the project John Hunter was
magnificent I forgot about doing this
some busy working 2 o'clock in the
afternoon John Hunter arrives at work in
Chicago I get an email saying thank you
very much for this that was wonderful
have you thought about doing this this
and what long story short he gave me
about three weeks work to do on the
train and when we added these tables
down below and he said can you make a an
example for the gallery and if you've
used matplotlib the best thing about it
you go to the gallery and you find the
graph that looks like the one you want
to do and you click on it and you find
the code that makes it happen
so I did this example for him and sent
it off and and I was pleasantly
surprised when I came back to do this
talk somebody is in the meanwhile tidied
it up changed the color palette now I
don't know how they were allowed to do
that because you have no idea the
arguments we had at work about what
color these different things should be
so moving on like I said event-driven
development so we're now in early 2004
and one of my colleagues had there was
this newfangled language well it was new
to the reinsurers called c-sharp and
everyone's like you should be using
c-sharp for everything so I said well
let's experiment on a system so somehow
we never used the claimed system because
we were reinsuring when you're doing
reinsurance nine years out of ten you
collect the premium and you don't pay
out any money the 10th year you give all
the money back basically because the
disaster happens so the least important
system we aren't was the claim system so
this poor guys is teaching himself
c-sharp he's trying to get his head
around all the concepts he's writing
this claim system called claims too and
again he should have wrong because it
was a replacement for an existing system
don't do that what happens 2004 was the
year of the four hurricanes as I know it
there were four hurricanes Charlie
Francis Ivan and Jeanne that hit Florida
all in the same year suddenly the claim
system became the most important system
in the company and not only that it grew
a lot of new requirements because nobody
had thought we might have two claims
from the same company in the same year
and we didn't just get two we got three
and four
none of these hurricanes are actually
Charlie Francis Ivan Jean but actually
this one in the bottom corners kind of
interesting anybody know what that might
be it's kind of this is the Bahamas and
this is the Azores and and this is
actually Bermuda and it's was back in
January of this year a storm formed down
in the Bahamas it tracked nor went just
north of Bermuda we had a pretty stormy
Friday night got up in the morning and
the patio furniture was next door again
and I went back and got it it tracked
across the Atlantic and in January its
intensified and hit the Azores as a
hurricane so we're having hurricanes in
January you're not supposed to it's not
supposed to happen the ocean was only
72 it wasn't as warm people say you have
to be 26 degrees before you get a
hurricane it's not actually true what
matters is the difference in temperature
between the ocean and the upper
atmosphere and that but together with
the heat in the ocean and the upper
atmosphere was exceptionally cold at
that time
I like this picture here this was this
tree was knocked down by fail Gonzalo
I'm not sure which what they do in
Bermuda is after the trees have been
knocked down in the storms they come
along with a crane and they pick them
back up and then they tie them to the
nearby trees to support them for a bit
this trees now thriving fantastic stuff
so moving forward to today there's a
project that's been bubbling along for a
few years now to create an open loss
model framework all the models that I've
been using up until this point
proprietary lost models they cost
several million dollars to license and
they basically you feed all your
insurance policy data into them and they
spit out a lost curve for you they have
sort of maybe 10,000 or 50,000
hypothetical years of of events and as I
say your feed your data and you get your
numbers out the Oasis people have been
trying to create an open framework which
will allow one one of the problems that
we're having with the commercial models
is there's there's lots of fantastic
research going on new ideas new insights
new data it takes too long for these
commercial companies to incorporate them
in the models so so what they're trying
to do with Oasis is create an open
framework where anybody can play and
also they want to separate the the
hazard model which sort of tells you
what you know like what the wind speeds
going to be at each location for each of
your hypothetical storms from the
vulnerability model which is you know
given that there was a 70 mile an hour
wind how much damage was done to your
house
and then separately on top of that they
given the damage how much is the
insurance claim gonna be this young guy
this this plot here was created by those
young guy here Becky to Bermudian guy
who was working with Oasis and they
tried it they decided they needed a an
example to help people understand how
the model works and builders so Peter
Taylor who was leading the project he
said well let's let's do a toy win store
model for a mythical town we'll will
base it on melt melton mowbray but we
won't call it melton mowbray we'll call
it ty because they make good pies in
melton mowbray so an interesting this
this plot here again was created by
Beckett with matplotlib so move on a few
years I think it was 2011 2012 there was
three earthquakes in quick succession or
over a period of 18 months in
Christchurch in New Zealand they were a
magnitude about six and a half between
six and a half and seven most of the
catastrophe models that the reinsurers
are using make the assumption that
earthquakes occur independently
following basically a sort of Poisson
distribution so they they weren't really
expecting to get three earthquakes in
the same place and some for most of the
deals they write their one-year deals
you're on the hook for a year so even
though as we know you know you do get
these aftershocks and all the rest of it
it's a reasonable approximation what
they had but but most of these companies
lost a lot of money by not modeling this
as it should have been they should have
realized when the first quake came along
in it in Christchurch there's a
reasonable chance of another big one and
his elevated chance and they should have
adjusted the models they didn't when
else cuz the other thing that was
interesting in Christchurch was that I
turned out that the soil in Christchurch
one of the things that happens when you
get an earthquake is this thing called
liquefaction so if there's a lot of
moisture in you
in new soil when when the earth starts
to shake it literally turns into a
liquid and this causes a lot of damage
obviously and I thought that the soil on
which you built turns into a liquid your
buildings going to collapse so although
it was only a 6.5 earthquake in
Christchurch you did a lot more damage
than they were expecting because of the
the poor soil quality guess what the
models haven't taken that into account
they were there were simple models they
didn't really include information on the
soil so the message of this is that what
we've been using for the past sort of 20
years and what I call black box models
because the companies that sell you them
are very proud of their proprietary
secret source inside the boxes which
means you can't see inside for what
they're actually doing so it's a bit
like the schrödinger's cat experiment
only worse that you've got your black
box and you don't really know whether
inside the cat's sleeping or it's turned
into a dead bird so you're making a wish
you put your data and you make a wish
and hope it works that's that's the
world on which and and and there's
billions of dollars being traded on the
strength of these models now I don't
want to making them sound worse than
they are it turns out there's so much
uncertainty in what's being done that
that really all you need from the model
is a signal something to detect the
signal from the noise and be able to
compare deals and is this a good one and
is this one better than that you know is
the risk better and so on and there's
lots of other kind of soft issues that
you have to take into account in that if
any you know some insurers have a much
stricter underwriting policy some of
them are just desperate to you know the
Repsol you ring them up and and they'll
find ways to keep your premium down to
get your business again back to the
present day this is just north of Ottawa
in Quebec that picture on the right was
taken in early January 2015 this was
Christmas Day it it was plus 17 degrees
in Quebec
it was 70 degrees in Quebec you could
have gone for a swim in the lake you
know things are changing in our planet
it's time to invest in your
solar-powered clothes dryers world's
heating up this again we got matplotlib
to thank for this picture and and also
the European Centre for medium-range
weather forecasting they have a
fantastic data set of of what they call
reanalysis data they've got 40 years of
what they for every day in the last 40
years you can get a whole bunch of
temper variables so you can get the
maximum temperature minimum temperature
the precipitation the amount of
evaporation from the planet and the
photo radiation are just five of the
variables and it's on a point seven five
degree grid I'll just like them because
you can just you just suck in the data
and you just plot it with him so on my
problems they look beautiful but but
this data set is was created by running
Neuman for every day in that period
they've run the numerical weather
prediction in Ischl eyes with the with
the best guess of what the weather was
like that you know that the the in the
all the readings they had for that day
and it's it allows us to create a
baseline to compare the current day to
very very valuable event setting if
there's anybody here from the
meteorology office love to talk to you
more about that data another big thing
that's going on at the moment cyber risk
Zurich reinsurance just announced that
cybercrime was costing four hundred and
forty five billion dollars a year now
they they're interested in insuring you
against cybercrime so their estimate may
be a little bit questionable but it's
certainly cost emoni my own view again
the word cyber actually in the field of
cybernetics is actually about the
feedback and control it's nothing to do
with computers directly but I do feel
that the way well we're in at the moment
with computers and information security
it's a bit like riding a tandem where
nobody's steering from the front we know
that we're in a little bit of a crisis
in that way and it does concern me I
think it should be a big concern to the
insurance companies with data leaking
out left right and center
you know it's creating a lot of
uncertainty in the world back to Oasis
so this is really the solar world that
we're living in computerize it's strung
together with string it's a little bit
frightened it just about works with the
with the best open source tools out
there I think we can build something
like that it's not the best bridge in
the world but I'd rather cross the one
on the right and at least it leads to a
nice oasis on the far side we've also
got some fantastic tools from the Python
community and from free software in
general pandas and and I don't know
whether you can see that slide but
actually that's Jupiter the little white
dot the big red dot is actually a drone
that was flying above me how this it was
a little bit scary the key thing here is
these tools are fantastic at this point
these the the software problem you know
there's a million solutions to every
problem you have this magic at your
fingertips use it these these steps are
in Bermuda the beautiful is it there's
an organization called chew stick and
they do art about the town and you just
walk around the corner and you see
something like this I've got a little
project to do with weather data and this
is the only plug for my own stuff in it
I've don't know whether it'll most of my
projects kind of start and then I find
somebody else who's already doing it
better but I call it karma pie this is
salty and he's no longer with us I'm
afraid but he was a great cut of mine
karma pie the idea with it is
distributed global data and and to
spread the load of serving that data
because there's a lot of data out there
again I mentioned that weather data what
you find is you have to sign up and if
you want to get access to most of the
data they have to cover the cost of the
bandwidth and all the rest of it it gets
expensive and that gets inhibits people
like myself and people like you who are
wanting to analyze data you have an idea
you think maybe I could use that weather
data then you find you have to spend
$3,000 to get it
so karma pie is an idea where I want to
be able to host it on on raspberry pies
and distribute the work and the idea
with it I'm calling it karma pie because
you play nicely you get out of it what
you put into it I'd love to talk more
about that sad no hear John Hunter who
who created matplotlib was an absolutely
fantastic guy if you want a model for
running an open-source project you
couldn't hope for better the
encouragement he gave me was was
unbelievable Peter Taylor started the
Oasis project and the elseís project is
is hopeful at they're planning on
opening open sourcing the code later
this year it's just coming to a critical
point both these people are no longer
with us they both became ill with cancer
and passed but they're I like to think
you know we saw the talk this morning
about the the black holes John hunters
matplotlib was used all over the place
in the LIGO analysis so those guys are
creating ripples in space-time and
shaping our future and you know I mean
immensely grateful to the help that I've
had over the years in my career I like
to think as well we're all we've all
worked really hard to master some of
these tools and we're all standing on
top of our own little Everest but I
encourage you to look around and look at
the hill over there there might be some
Ruby programmers over there that have
got something useful or our programmers
or they some more data and when you get
on the top of a hill you can you can see
where you're going a lot of the time
we're struggling up the hill and we
can't see the giant mountain behind but
you know there's great tools out there
there's data everywhere there's
wonderful opportunities in but we've got
some difficult problems we've got a
delicate planet that needs a little bit
of care and TLC again this is in the in
the ferry terminal in Bermuda and it's
little collage the schoolchildren made
and underneath it there's a quote from
Mark Twain which says throw off the
bowlines sail away from the safe harbor
catch the trade winds in these
and explore dream and discover and I
invite everyone here to you know take
these tools take the day to probe around
see what you're going to discover and
and and be you know build on we're all
working with the work of some great
people here that's really all I got to
say now the sunshine is quite nice in
Bermuda - so do I do comment if we
organize play data there which
apparently is mostly down to me doing
some things so I need to find some
people that help me do come on that do
come on visit so that's all I've got a
safe today
excellent no questions
oh one again so this the weather data
came from the European Centre for
medium-range weather forecasting and if
you go to their website they have a you
have to I think you have to sign up for
something they have a quite a complex
API and it takes you half a morning to
figure out which day to you one each
variable if you just wash it down to a
floating-point number this 14 gigabytes
of data per variable so it can be a
little bit expensive you know
downloading what you want and what have
you and obviously you don't want to do s
the server if everybody goes and gets
their data then that's part of the idea
with with the karma pie idea is that
these I want I want I do a lot of work
with schools and that in Bermuda and I
want to make the data available to the
schoolchildren so that they can see
what's happening in the planet at large
but the this this thing here has got
running guidos clock on an 8x8 grid it
doesn't it's great for when you want a
clock that you can't tell the time with
but it's also got a a pressure sensor a
humidity sensor and accelerometer
and it's got a compass and a couple of
temperature sensors so it's a mini
weather station so this thing you put an
SD card with with you know 64 gigs of
space on it we could have most of the
weather data available what we can do is
we could store that if that's too much
data to store on one we can aggregate it
up and have the baselines so that each
of these PI's which only cost about 60
70 dollars with the sense Act we can
have little mini weather stations all
over the place and it's my belief that
small islands like Bermuda if they don't
study their own climate and understand
what climate change is going to mean for
them nobody else is going to do it for
them and I'm hoping that what we can do
is use local expertise and there's a lot
of local expertise about how to deal
with hurricanes in Bermuda when when III
these were the first two hurricanes I
went through Fay and Gonzalo and it was
fantastic I talking to locals and I got
you know ten life-saving tips about how
to go through a hurricane from the local
people who've been through it before so
I think if we can share the global data
and the work and we were already doing
that by creating all this wonderful
software and then help different
locations
you know I explained to each other and
have conversations about what climate
change is going to mean for us because
then then we can maybe reach some
consensus about how the world's going to
deal with all that change anymore
I tell me about it
yeah I I so I I was very very fortunate
in the come I'll mention the company I
was at from so from about 97 12 2009 was
Renaissance reinsurance and I was very
fortunate that that they kind of let me
do my thing and I was I was fortunate I
was producing good stuff for them
I'm currently consulting to another
company and it's a nightmare to be quite
honest I you know the CIO said to me why
can't you use dotnet and sequel server I
didn't know and III asked well can we
use can you put yourself software on I
can't even get them to get all the
software into Team Foundation server so
it's it's challenging the and I think
don't be confrontational be patient I
think the big I think what's actually
going to happen is Microsoft are going
to lead those companies to Linux I don't
know whether you know Windows 10 has
Ubuntu embedded in it in you know I'm
not quite sure how it works it's there's
a bit of black magic in there but I you
know Microsoft is is moving to Linux now
and what it's not moving directly but
it's embracing that it's making it
easier to work with from there trouble
is that my company they they're on
Windows 7 and it'll be another of the
current pace it'll be three or four
years before they get to Windows 10 it's
it's difficult you know have you got
other friends who find others that the
kindred spirits
yeah the other I think so I think the
other big tip anaconda pythons good
because she can install it without admin
privileges and and if you if it's not in
an account their distribution has pretty
much everything you might need so that
helps but it's it's a challenge and we
could talk some more about tips on that
but any more well thank you very much